for some parents and for some students
it can really be stressful picking just
the right School the right fit to help a
child really succeed too so in Clark
County the district does offer 42 magnet
programs and some having been nationally
recognized for their student achievement
Joshua peguero explains what Magna
schools are and how a student can be
considered
eighth graders at Hyde Park Middle
School are learning their options for
high school among them Abigail kowas
there's a lot of good schools and a lot
of them do have medical and theater I
need to be happy and to know that I'm in
a positive environment to work well
several teachers also sharing
information about their Magnus schools
time and time again we have been awarded
for our efforts in terms of creating
these amazing schools the Magna schools
offer Specialties in the Arts stem and
Industry trades students need to apply
for consideration and must meet certain
criterias before their name is added to
a lottery I think it it's really about
being in tune with your child's
interests their talents and abilities
next year Clark County Schools opens the
Northeast Career and Technical Academy
in North Las Vegas it's next to Legacy
High School on Deer Springs near North
5th Street a milestone in providing a
magnet education for that area as you
can see construction is still on the way
at this high school and parents need to
act quick if they want their kids to be
considered for it because the deadline
for the lottery is January 10th in
principal Ryan Cordia is trying to get
600 students to enroll so my goal as
principal is to make sure everyone
leaves with access to Affordable College
High skill work and Military careers so
we're going to make sure they give four
years of Industry training and a career
trade so they can go get paid right away
the majority of the Magna schools are a
lottery Las Vegas Academy and Del Sol
Academy require additions and if you're
worried how your child can get to and
from these schools the district provides
Transportation Joshua pagero eight news
now
if you want to learn more about these
magnet schools there is a free event
that you can attend with your child it's
tomorrow at the Las Vegas Academy which
by the way is in downtown Las Vegas
they're on 7th Street that's going to be
from nine to noon so you can meet the
students you can talk to teachers from
these schools and learn more about what
they have to offer for your child and
your family